hallo mein name ist supernett sich
willkommen heute es ist montag und ich
bin fertig ich das heute schon so ca 10
millionen jahre im stau verdichten so
ein toller tag aber dafür hab ich mir
gedacht wir zocken heute mal wieder
akinator weil das ja auch schon länger
nicht kam
ich bin hier schon in dem fragen menü
drin das ist frage nummer eins und zwei
ihr habt den titel schon gelesen
deswegen muss das thema glaube ich gar
nicht sagen wir gucken nämlich heute ob
der akinator clever bot kennt das sind
zwei formate die ich lange zeit sehr
lange auf lange sehr sehr sehr lange
tatsächlich beides der lange zeit auf
meinem kanal regelmäßig hoch klar
deswegen wollte ich mal schauen ob der
akinator clever bot kennt ist eine figur
weiblich das weiß ich leider nicht
lieber clever bot jetzt das ist jetzt
gut direkt bei frage an nummer eins der
kino gala abgestürzt hallo geht's noch
mal weiter hier anstatt das ganze mal
von vorne und zwar ist eine figur
männlich das weiß ich leider auch nicht
wo du deine figur durch youtube berühmt
ich würde mal sagen wahrscheinlich
gehört eine figur zu helferlein
das ist dass in diesem komischen
gezeichneten figuren hier die ganze zeit
mit gregs tagebuch und so das hab ich
auch selber mal gelesen nein meine figur
göttert nicht zu hatte eine figur etwas
man elektrizität zu tun in gewisser form
ich meine es ist eine website und
webseiten werden mit elektrizität wird
mal sagen nein lebt eine figur im jedi
tempel das tut sie auch nicht sie ist
auch nicht aus liv und melli und ja sie
hat etwas mit konkreter zu tun ist ein
agitator der akinator ist weg wenn die
figur ist nicht aus holz ab da ist er
wieder der kleine mann weil die figur
ist auch keine flasche sie kommen nicht
im kika vor kennt deine figur elf wie
ich denke ja weil es ist der clip warum
ist er denn der weg übrigens schaut euch
mein t shirt an das ist noch nicht
verfügbar was nice das ist dass der
konkret dass miley unruhig genug
gespielt oder installieren was hat eine
figur krallen 9 hat die figur 2 auf
dieses shirt besitze ich schon zusammen
mit diesen anderen staat was ich auch
schon besitzt und zwar diese mir herr
lukas macht keinen sinn dass du dafür
jetzt werbung macht weil das gibt es
erst im nächsten lukasz ob also es lohnt
sich trotzdem mal im café dass sie dort
mal vorbeischaut weil es da dauerhaft
irgendwelche aktionen gibt aber die dass
hier was ich gerade an habe und das
weiße und dazu noch ein kissen das kommt
demnächst aber ja das wollte ich nur
schon mal sagen weil ich habe es an weiß
geil finde ihr habt eine figur zwei
augen das ist jetzt die sache und zwar
es gibt ja mehrere versionen vom clever
bot es gibt ja einmal den der neue
website ist um den der augen hat
deswegen sage ich mal ich für dich ich
sag mal nein kann man auf deine figur
sitzen oder stehen nein gehört eine
figur kraft dann nein ist eine figur
katholischen nein hat eine figur beinen
ein standort im internet die ja spricht
eine figur mit dir ja denn ich bin
unwahrscheinlich großen busen oder dem
chef der mich immer fragte sie hat
keinen unwahrscheinlich großen busen der
name meiner figur fängt nicht mit es
ankam
sie kann sich nicht bewegen das ist
jetzt nicht wahr
ich bin der akinator hat mich echt
albinoni enttäuscht ja clever bot ist
regen 6000 mal wurde schon der clever
wort gespielt alter meine herren
gesangsvereine stadt eine menge damit
haben wir jetzt herausgefunden dass der
akinator den clever bot kennt kennt denn
der akinator sich selbst eigentlich der
akinator lebt nicht wirklich der
akinator ist kein tier der akinator
keine beine er trägt einen schnurrbart
er hat keine allergie arbeitet eine
figur in sky office sky office das
office dass das büro von dem von dem
sportsender sky oder sky office heißt
als dass es ein bewohner luft ist weil
er schwebt ja in der luft eigentlich und
das ist seine arbeit ich sag mal ich
weiß nicht sie hat ja gewissen format
mit
dazu tun sie kommt nicht aus offenbach
am main ich weiß nicht ob die nato eine
schwester hat der ja keener kommt aus
einer flasche ich bleibe das im
hintergrund hier ist nicht köln oder sie
spielt bei einem englischen verein sie
spricht gerade mit mir ich denke
angelina torten namen ja es ist jen und
john 4700 mal als ob so selten der erst
gespielt wurde
wir haben jetzt heute den clever bord
gesucht und den akinator aber wenn wir
noch nie gesucht haben ist die flasche
aus der der akinator kommt meine figur
hat nichts mit sex zu tun sie hat nicht
weiß nicht ob sie was mit technologie zu
tun hat sie stammt aus
ja sie stammt aus einem spiel ja sie ist
aus metall sie hat etwas mit zauberei zu
tun sie macht keine kämpfe sie spielt
mit in aladdin und die wunderlampe ich
denke an akinator wunderlampe ja
natürlich die die wunderlampe von ihm
wurde mehr als doppelt so magisch damit
zufrieden
ich kann nicht reden die wunderlampe
wurde mehr als doppelt so oft gespielt
wie der akinator selbst wenn das nicht
mal ein statement ist an dieser stelle
beende ich das video meine damen und
herren wenn euch wieso nur vollgas
gefahren will ich mich um eine bewertung
freuen falls ihr weitere ideen habt soll
ich mal wieder murphy bord hochladen
solch mal wieder clever bord hochladen
soll ich mal wieder sims hochladen
irgendwas was wünscht ihr euch schreibt
mir games in die kommentare ich habe
unmenschlich viele ideen für ihr live
video seines neue faq formate ihr seine
videos zu an ganz normale real life
formate sache über dich reden könnte
aber games technisch ist bei mir derzeit
so ein bisschen flaute so ich weiß nicht
genau so was mögt ihr was wollt ihr
sagte mir doch einmal den kommentaren
und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten video
wieder haut rein was mache ich hier mit
meiner hand schon wieder das ist das ist
das sieht sehr komisch aus